Pinsky okay so thanks so this is the
last of last talk of the workshop and by
now I think we were like many mechanism
design talks most of them we had like
some specific setting in mind probably
an auction setting and you know we had
some specific specific goal in mind
maybe maximize revenue or well first I
could be nation or well but not in this
talk I want to do something that is
slightly more basic and i'm just going
to fix any crucial mechanism and i'm
going to define to complexity to notions
of the complexity of this a mechanism
and then study the relationship between
them so the first notion that they go to
define is a standard one and this is the
communication complexity of the auction
or mechanism in general so here we have
like two players with some valuations v1
v2 we have some center the players
exchange bits who's the center until we
get some selective and the associated
payments okay so what is the
communication complexity you know until
you the thing it's the maximum number of
bits it is exchanging in any instance
okay so we just count the number of bits
and we just take the maximum over all
instances for the second notion that I
want to define we need to recall the
taxation principle which basically says
that every truthful mechanism can be
interpreted interpreted and the
following way so lets you know think
about some player I and what the
accession principal say says is that
player I is implicitly presented with
some when you pee this menu bi this menu
p I simply functions as a sign surprised
to have a possible bundle this function
P I depends only as the valuations of
the others only develops of all players
but player I and the magic in a crucial
mechanism is that you know the selected
alternative X simultaneously maximizes
the prophet of all players so every
player every player is presented with
the menu that depends on all other
players but our player and you know some
of the crucial mechanism and manages to
as
an alternative that maximizes the
prophet of all of them together so now
that we have the taxation principle we
can define the taxation complexity of a
mechanism to be the following so let's
first define the succession complexity
of their I so let's fix some player I
and very all possible valuations of the
others so that's very v minus I okay and
then just count the number of menus that
are presented to this player okay so
this is the number of menu that I
presented this player is going to be the
taxation complexity of Claire I and the
taxation complexity of a mechanism is
simply you know we simply take a maximum
over and over the over this number so
you know what's the maximum number of
menus that is presented to any of our
players okay so this is the succession
complexity of a crucial mechanism and in
fact it will be a bit easier to work
with the taxation indexing complexity
which is simply log of the taxation
complexity so this is the nom de number
of bits that we need in order to
represent an index in this set okay so
if you want to point out on a specific
mechanism is set of all possible menus
this is the number of bits that minute
are you finished up there so we want
like you know just to make sure that
everybody not assessed we only care
about the number of menus that a
truthful mechanism is presenting us or
presenting the player we don't care
about the structure of the menus with
not going to count the number of finite
prices in the menu or what else not
going to say anything about the
structure of the menu we're just going
to count the number of menus at the
player can see you say may as a function
as a function of graduations of the
others yes yes you go over all possible
valuations of the other bidders and yet
yeah and you just see okay okay
do you mean the maximum number of
entries will the menu no no no no exact
exactly the number of menus that there
may see so let's fix some instance
affiliations of the bidders you know so
yeah there is one menu that is
presenting Daniel let's go over the set
of all possible values of the others and
let's see when these menu changes now
the number of menus that is presented to
sync up their de su the succession of
laxity okay this is the number of
management may be presented to player
which is work life like this comes to
the taxation principle if you ask why
it's called succession principle so
apparently it came from some book on
taxation an actual taxation as far as
I've been able to tell so just using the
neck maybe it's not like the best angle
self-immolation mechanism so the
relationship represent the player with
the list of prices or taxes has to pay
for different options so that's the main
you yeah thnkx called maximal and not
much move-in system number I mean yes
okay okay are we good with this
definition
okay so the main theorem says like
informally and I'll give a more precise
statement later that the taxation index
in complexity is at most the
communication complexity of the of the
mechanism okay this is like the main
theorem so we give a connection between
the two between the two notions and what
they plan to do in the rest of the talk
is to talk some of the applications and
extensions of this of the theorem to
actually prove it but first like you
know so I mean maybe some of you may
think that this is like a trivial
statement so I want actually to give
like a counterexample to this to this
theorem so you sort of like appreciate
that it's not like a trivial statement
so okay so what I wanted to show is that
there is some crucial mechanism a with
the following two properties first the
communication complexity of a is C and
second the taxation indexing complexity
of the mechanism is like exponential NC
so not only that the communication
complexity that the tech sector that
application complexity is not bounded
from above by the communication
complexity the gap between them is
actually a huge sometimes okay the the
like the mechanism a is simply going to
be vcg of platica material options when
the valuations of the bidders are gross
substitutes and what we got to do now
just know quickly go over all these all
these terms and then i'll show you why
this process the claim why we have a gap
between the fixation complexity and
communication process
I'll give like a precise statement of
the theorem later okay so committed
options I guess you all know it by now
so we have n players then we have a
mature genius items as usual the private
information at the private information
for each player's got to be the relation
the value that he gives to each possible
subset of the items and we're going to
have no external tease continously at
normalized valuations and we're looking
for a partition of the items for this
example we need the valuations to also
be gross substitutes the exact
definition is not very important for the
purposes of this talk so let's keep it
okay so I want to study now the vc vc g
mechanism applied to collateral options
with gross subsidy withers and first
time that this mechanism has small
communication so we call that in order
to find the to compute the GCD mechanism
we have to find the welfare maximizing a
location like and if you can do that we
can compute prices and there are a
number of ways that you can do that with
small communication one of them is via
an ascending auction there is certainly
no program that one can I can solve
efficiently and also gives you the
optimal solution and you know if you
want strongly polynomial time algorithms
there are also ways to do that okay so
you can do all that now let's see why
the taxation complexity of the of the
VCG mechanism is huge for that let's
consider vcg for only two players let's
fix one just play one and let's call
this valuation v what is the menu that
what many player one is presenting to
the other player so or more precisely
let's fix unban little s what is the
price of that bundle if the other player
is going to take that bundle this is
just the damage to society that varies
causing is usually BCG so it's the value
of the grand Bandar manage the value of
the complement of s right with the
finishing
so this is the this is the minimum BCG
the tease you know for every further
evaluation of the player we're going to
get like a different menu right because
the value of s determine is completely
the value of the compliment value of s
the price of the complement the bundle
fest in the menu okay so we have a
one-to-one correspondence between the
menu that the player is presenting and
his valuation and this gives us that the
tech session complexity in vc g equals
to the number of possible valuations
right so all we have to notice now is
that the number of growth suffrage
evaluations on em items when the value
star between our integer between 0 and m
is actually w exponential in em okay so
we get that it accession complexity is w
exponential we take log of this number
to have the succession indexing
complexity and we get that the accession
indexing capacity explains exponential
all the communication complexity is
polynomial okay so now we can give like
a more precise statement of my theorem
so I let a bit useful mechanism for
collateral options with general
valuations we also have like it don't
see it we also have like similar similar
versions for other classes let's call it
communication complexity see and it's a
taxation index equal to indexing
complexity then the succession indexing
complexity is it mostly communication
complexity plus one
so connecting with your previous example
when this theorem applies we're talking
about exponential taxation these
valuations include gross substitute
right mention already all right well
this isn't it like when this is all the
holes we're already talking about
exponential community happiness oh
that's a good point so let's think about
this way the algorithm for gossip usable
for you know finding a welfare
maximizing allocations focus of stitute
videos actually you know using a very
specific way the structure of course our
situation they not going to be useful if
you have more like more general classes
evaluations so this is just like you
know having a multiplicity on a single
product or does not apply that your
monotone on larger domain like a
multi-parameter to me so so that's the
issue right just not useful when the set
of possible deviations if you wish is
larger when you have like more types
that are available it doesn't apply
right i mean i mean the algorithms for
gossip sheets are not useful when you
use them on you know algorithms for that
are truthful for general obligations
okay so the theorem applies here and
does not apply for brussels insulation
ok so the stars the store is like some
other our accessibility still still like
not subject which is good because I it's
not your footwear for a substance yeah
Ricky mutation complexity I think that
is a property problem
using the communication costs in the
mechanism like the communication plexi
of the location functionalism reduced
five minutes yeah I mean take the lowest
communication complexity of the
allocation function yeah take the
minimum like the best implementation
that you can to be there like the
communication complexity questions
alright so this is the first theorem the
taxation indexing complexity for region
of domain is it most like communication
capacity plus 1 and sends the compliment
theorem says that in animal is a for
collateral auctions n minus 1 players
can find the menu that is presented to
the remaining player using only num
yellow in TN see many bits in other
words if we take these two together we
know that you know for greater access to
general valuation then the taxation
index income tax is must-see so we can
find you can find the menu that is
presented to the other player like a
relatively quick way without paying too
much more than you know what a location
function is doing so if we take them
together we get that we can you know
sort of transform any collateral options
for any mechanism Foca matter options
with general valuations to a mechanism
that simply explicitly presents each
bidder with the set of options but it
has decided no with the menu so you know
you can tell it's bitter you either take
that this or that and each video just
simply chooses its profit maximization
evaluation it's not completely accurate
what they said but this is more
in particular the menu there is a
protocol that uses that many bits and
which I can you know like tell you this
is the menu that is the money or what it
is between the n minus 1 remaining
players so they exchanged the extended
bit we have plans you know that yeah all
right in a sense another way to think
about that is as the following so in the
grass substitute example we sort of
we're able to do like smart optimization
ok so we managed to find the problem a
profit maximizing battle without like
learning the all set of menus that is
presented to the player ok in this case
it's simply impossible you know if you
can if you can decide what is the
winning bundle and what are the
associated prices you can as well you
know just show me the full menu this is
almost the same thing ok updo like these
polynomial factors
all right yep this imply that it seems
to me the theorem to implies that if
player 1 can answer arbitrary queries
about this valuation then you get that
mechanism because all you do is still in
the menu and if you can tell you what
his favorite is let's almost implant
implies the mechanism for two players
that all did I mean this also model more
than two players what you said actually
it's a good point it it's true for two
players there is like an annoying issue
of tiebreaking so there are several
bundles that you know you can take and
the maximize your profit which one do
you take is sort of similar to what
Aaron was discussing before and actually
this is like unavoidable like for
example there are like an annoying
annoying like examples where the for two
players were the succession complexity
is one but the communication complexity
exponential look stupid example it's so
it to be delicate this ish this you know
small small issue of tiebreaking is
actually make it quite annoying
more questions okay let's talk about
some application of extensions of that
theorem and i'm going to give you like
for extension applications and quickly
go over all we'd go over in the first
three ones and spend a little bit more
time on the fourth so the first one is
strengthening the solution concept so if
you have a mechanism that implements
some sort of choice function via an
extra stash equilibrium we can we can
like you know you can use the relation
principle and get for free like a
mechanism that implement the same sort
of choice function in dominant
strategies the problem is that the
communication blow off of this is
exponential just as we saw and sensing
the goshawk suitcase there is just too
much information that one is to just one
of two have to send if you use like
fixations an ad similar to watch other
incidences before what you have to be
like you have to be careful gives you
that for 2-player mechanisms we can you
know get for free this strengthening of
the solution concept we can transform
any extra stash mechanism to a dominant
strategy one the communique should blow
up is like like a multiplicative factor
of three of something like that so
really not a lot so this is one thing
other thing is efficient price
computation so here's just a few years
ago to study the following gear issues
so we have the cuban cash complexity of
the allocation function which is you
know do some number but then we also
want to computer prices how much
communication overhead we had to do it
pain in a sense in a sense what we're
doing is is showing that the
communication I mean not only finding
the individual of domain not only that
finding the associated process is not
such an easy task but you can actually
also find a full menu like
relatively fast okay so up until now we
didn't say anything about the structure
of the menu and this is unavoidable like
in general in general communication
model there is sort of nothing you can
say about that like it can be completely
crazy but if you restrict the infra
stick the valuation function if you
stick the access to the bioship function
to be like a natural aquarius a demand
or value queries then you can actually
get a nice characterization of the
structure of this of these menus and I
want to spend a little bit more time on
new projects to proving the limits of
computationally efficient use of
mechanisms and we'll discuss two
possible ways that this succession based
approach gives us one is via
simultaneous algorithms and the other
one is more direct one the other one on
the tech station complexity so I'm going
to discuss about the metal objects with
some other of bidders what I'm going to
say applies almost you know with
different numbers to almost every
setting other settings that you care
about so we know that you exist
something like 1.57 approximation for
the wealth of comet or oxygen fuser
model bidders and this uses only poor
normally benefits design with them and
you know now this is not true so
algorithm and now we want to access all
truthfulness and unfortunately the best
to deterministic algorithm that we know
uses only for normal communication
everything that I say with different
values is going to apply also for
randomized mechanisms this guarantee is
only an approximation ratio of spirit of
em and the obvious question is like
what's the right answer for truthful and
algorithms we really don't know how to
approach this problem
the sense that okay fine we have some
possibilities with this is only for this
very special case where we accessed
evaluations only via valuers but if you
have demand queries more general models
and so on we just don't know what the
answer is and moreover I mean it's not
even clear out the project we really
have no like way of attacking this
problem and again I want to suggest two
approaches to attacking this problem and
the first approach is going to be our
reduction to estimate a nice algorithm
so let's maybe say first what is
sometimes I agree with them too so this
is the model with Norman Segal this
model with Norman Segal that you know we
have a bunch of players each of them
just look at their own valuations as
they speak simultaneously say sending
your message of polynomial length and
based only on this message without any
interaction between the players one has
to output an allocation that will be
approximately good and in general we
have like horrible horrible bounds on
the performance of such of such
mechanisms like the approximation ratio
ratios are really bad we know that now
if you have two players it turns out
that one can reduce average useful
algorithm to simultaneous algorithm so a
little bit more formally if there is a
two-player alpha proxima intrusion
mechanism then there is a two-player
alpha proxima approximations
simultaneously with them with the same
communication so you take one you take
to talk with them and the reason with an
essay is no tennis algorithm that you
know gives you the same proximity ratio
with the say communication complexity so
all you have to do now is to prove that
no scimitars algorithm for two players
can achieve an approximation ratio of
1.5 feet and we left like the first gap
between to sue logarithms and
not just like with them so this is all
you have to do and we sort of know how
to do such things if we have many
players right this is got what we did
what we did before proved like bounce on
and the performance of algorithms with
many players fortunately we don't know
how to do that for two players so you
know this is all you have to do and you
get a gap okay so the second project i
want to suggest is a little bit more
direct simply by giving a lot of under
the taxation indexing complexity this
should be complexity i guess so okay so
you know we know that the communication
complexity bounce from above the
taxation ethics and complexity so all
you have to show that the tech session
indexing complexity of every
approximation algorithm that gives like
a good approximation is huge and you're
done that's it and in both of these
approaches we sort of can you know stop
thinking about resorcinol these are just
like converter statements about
properties of approximation algorithms
may be simultaneous one but you know
that's all and this is all that is left
to prove in order to prove gaps okay I'm
saying that
so what's the proof of this of this
theorem I'm going to start with some
mechanism you know if its accession
index in complexity of 80 and its
communication complexity by by sea and
I'm going to take the original mechanism
and slightly changing we're going to
have two players Laurel and Hardy here
and all is going to send a bit of one at
the end if its profit is positive and 0
otherwise okay so this is you know this
does not affect usefulness this is after
we have decided what the allocation are
is what what the payments are so this
not going to affect our truthfulness and
the communication complexity increases
by one that's all ok now we do the
following we're going to look at the
communication complexity that this guy
is presenting hardy I've been a set of
menu with this guy is presenting and
they're like you know there are a bunch
of menus our team menus like that or
maybe two to the tea menu something like
that and for every such menu we're going
to take like a presenta tver presented
evaluation so this valuation v1 presents
p 1 V 2 presents v2 v3 plan B 3 and so
on so forth okay so we have like 2 to
the T lines here
now what's the valuation of Adi for
every menu p 2 p 3 we're going to define
a mountain evaluation which look like
that the value of every bundle is simply
at the price so if we are if the price
of bundle s is 10 then the value for the
bundle acid is 10 as well we have to
make sure that this thing is monotone
there are actually other issues like
some some banners might get like like an
infinite price but you know that's not
really big problem that's not think
about it for now so so these are the
menus and we're going to have liked to
duty instances like that like the blue
instance the gradient between instance
to read instance in every one of them if
we've the menus p1 than the version of
the other guy is VP 1 so you know we're
going to observe what's going to happen
in each of these instances so you know
their extended bit and one thing that we
do want to observe that in all these
instances the last bit that thought is
going to stand is 0 why is it so because
we call that the last bit is 0 if the
Prophet is are not positive of 0 and
this is the case in any of this
valuation simply because we set the
value of the doctor player to be the
price so value minus price is 0 so the
last bit in any of these is going to be
0
okay now at the claim that you would
like to prove is that no two pairs of
the same transcript and this is enough
to prove the text indexing and
complexity that most communication
capacity plus one since we get that you
know this means that it moves to the
cheapest one project can be represented
can be represented well with c plus 1
bits like you know this is like a
standalone fact and this means that we
have at most to the c plus 1 menus okay
so we're going to show that in every of
these instances that transcript is
different but we know that the
communication complexity is mostly plus
1 which means that can have at most to
the c plus 1 different a transcript okay
which I mean since we have like a
transit for each menu this means that we
have at most t to the c plus 1 different
menus that can be presented okay so all
that is left to do is to prove this clam
yes sir
all right um okay so let's look use
maybe the most basic fact in
communication complexity if the
transcripts of an instance like say the
blue blue instance in the red red
instance are identical then at the
transit of the mixed sensors to take
like a blue and red or maybe red and
blue this transit must be identical as
well okay this is like a a basic fact
why is it so you know say the 30 is
sending one at the beginning of the
protocol in both the blue and red and
then you know if this guy's Caesar the
first [ __ ] was one he answers with 0
and this guy says you know if I send one
in the beginning 0 now and look at my
valuation I'm going to stand 0 then if
we mix the instance the same logic is
going to apply the red one doesn't know
who know we sent first sent the is first
bit it doesn't know if what the other
guy is so it's not just one okay and
then the blue guy you know replaces if
the other guy was below so you know it's
10 0 and so and so forth right so we
have this so this means that every mix
instance must have the same transcript
if the like the monochromatic in
monochromatic instances at the same
transcripts ok so now I want to claim
that either the blue red transcript or
the red blue transcript once the
diagonals as a difference as a different
transit than the blue blue traffic why
is it so let's look at the two men uses
the reduced p1 p2 and you know these
manuals are different so it must be that
there is someone the less where p1 s is
greater than P 2 s.o they are the
opposite way doesn't matter then what
does it mean it means that if vp1 is
presented with the p2 with the menu p to
his last wish is going to be one why is
that because it can take the value you
can take the bundle s is very for that
is p1 s but
definition of the valuation but the
price is lower so it's going to make a
positive profit maybe it's not going to
take s but there is somebody less from
which it takes some positive from each
for which you can make some positive
profit by the accession principle it
must be allocated this this bundle or
you know the profit maximizing bundle so
there is a bundle for which a make some
profit in particular this means that is
last best is last bit must be one and as
we said in all monochromatic instances
the last bit is 0 so this gives us the
contradictions that we wanted this means
that animal chromatic instance must have
different transcript which gives us a
bound
okay so let's summarize main theorem
says that for which F demands the
succession indexing complexity is
bounded from above where the
communication complexity and i showed
you also some possible application
extensions of this of this technique
like on warfare so freaking out in the
sense what happens here is like you know
we get a more direct connection between
the semantics of the social choice
function like accession number of menus
that are presented to the players to the
actual implementation of a to the
communication complexity of it and like
I think that the connection should be
quite clear right now and that's it
thank you randomized like very truthful
whoever doesn't matter for Tucson
expectation mechanisms actually there is
a Christian expectation mechanisms there
is like a huge huge gap between the
between the two this might give you like
maybe like going to give you a hint of
why certain domains are easy and why
certain domains are not so if you have
like a huge gap in the accession
complexity this might hint that you can
do like smart algorithms are doing
something interesting if not then you
know all you can do it stupid things and
we sort of know how to do all these
things moving set argue it does not
going to be so for randomized version so
this I think this is exactly what Tim
was asking what anyways what starting an
argument works only if you require the
things to be little chromatic right say
so ok I mean the theorem is not true for
true so my expectation mechanism so like
yeah yes that is one one one year like
one argument fails yeah so where does
this fraud argument break for gross
substitutes is it that the prices are
not grow substitutes valuation yeah
exactly I mean they're not some other
also for some other variations but then
we can do like yeah I can yeah you can
play with them but you're mean
apparently you can't do that it's
basically some question why is there a
plus one in your urine because you have
one like communication sequences but
under all the mentions here all right I
need another bits I me now maybe you can
remove that but you know yeah possibly
we can get rid of the plus one thing
there no more questions oh sorry Vince
so just to get back to Sharon's earlier
question so the solution to complexity
is really about figuring out how to
break the ties within menus right yeah
having you can implement I mean yeah
basically yes yeah I mean for two
players for example then the
communication complain I mean to
implement any mechanism is just like the
taxation complex I mean it's not that
exciting indexing complexity plus you
know how much it takes you to break ties
so for example for like natural things
like were for maximization it's easy to
do like in a way that makes with the
ball but since we don't restrict the set
of such a choice function you know it
can get like the logical cases but I
guess that's for everything that is like
make sense then this is not going to be
like a real problem
their move no more questions let's thank
the speakers and